foreign the yankees on their own
schedule this will be the 15th start of
the season for corey kluber fifth since
he's come off the il 5-3 record 3.68 era
for the right-hander 71 innings pitch so
far this season eight home runs allowed
and a pretty good strikeout rate at 25
straight three hernandez down looking
and one away and here is
isaiah kinder falefa
3-2 pitch this one in the air left
center field drops in base hit back in
the hit column tonight and continuing to
do what he does a nice job after getting
down on the count 1-2 he works it to a
full count gets a pitch that he can
handle pretty good looking pitch
swinging and miss got him there's that
left-hand turn two away kluber's got a
breaking ball package a cutter a slider
a curveball but he's always had more
side-to-side movement more horizontal
break on that breaking ball and you can
see
the spin makes a left-hand turn so
they're a two-way low is a left-hand
hitter he's at 262. here's the 2-2
and he struck him out swinging struck
out the side for texas snow runs one hit
one left and that lineup will face this
young lefty taylor hearn on the mound
tonight you can see kind of a mixed bag
start out the bullpen now gonna give his
chance and the rotation this will be the
seventh consecutive outing as a starter
it began back on august 17th and as we
said uh
he's going to get his chance because the
rangers need
starting uh pitching in their rotation
and he's been tough on lefties a 194
batting average against set by hearn and
the 02 to le mayhew and that's popped up
into short left field out goes connor
falefa he says he has it and he does and
there is one down here in the bottom of
the first the scoreless game and luke
voight is coming up and here's the pitch
a little bouncer hit the third brock
holt up with it across the diamond a
little bit low but low has no trouble
with it and there are two outs here in
the bottom of the first of a scoreless
game payoff pitch judge strikes out
swinging boy a nasty fastball down and
in at 97 and it's a one two three inning
for hearn
we'll see if perhaps the rangers can
actually break the ice with a hit for
the man in scoring position here's the
pitch and calhoon it's a bouncing ball
to first off the glove of void on the
backhand side out into right field here
comes garcia to score and the rangers
grab a one to nothing lead luke voight
reaching on the backhand side had that
ball graze off his mitt
well give taylor hearn an rbi here
because taylor hearn on the mound means
anthony rizzo is not in the lineup which
means luke boyd is playing first and he
doesn't make this play and anthony rizzo
is a fantastic first baseman now the
payoff
is grounded weakly to first voight will
flip to kluber so the play goes 3-1 one
run three hits and cuba
hearn is ready and delivers
there's a high fly ball deep center
field peters going back he's on the
track he's under it and he makes the
catch with a very slight jump and the
side is retired
warning track fly ball
ending the inning that brings up luke
voight voigt who grounded the third his
first time up the 2-2 pitch this is hit
on the ground left side and to it goes
kinder philippa he slides to the ball
picks it up goes to second for one on to
first for the double play
what a play by isaiah keiner falloffa
looked like that might squeeze between
him and holt but izzy goes sliding to a
knee on the outfield grass makes a neat
pick pops up and gets it over to second
and uh yoni turns that six four three
double play we'll go to the fourth
inning ranger still leading one nothing
peter's reached on the fielder's choice
his first time and hits this one high
and deep into left field joey gets
turned around still going back he's at
the wall he leaps and it's off the wall
it carrums over to gardner who picks it
up he'll fire it into third it's a
double off the left field wall for dj
peters and that looked like a ball
perhaps that joey could have caught
definitely could have caught it had he
taken a direct route to the ball i think
that's the most lost we have ever seen
joey gallo underneath the fly ball brett
gardner's out there making sure the
fence is okay he's replacing some of the
padding there so peter's in scoring
position for holt ninja's trying to add
a run to their lead holt in the air
back of third base and this looks like
trouble it drops in base hit and peters
running all the way he scores on the
blue by brock holt and it's two nothing
it's a pretty odd two out rally no
question about it brock in fact when he
hit that ball stayed in the batter's box
because he thought he had fouled it off
but it ends up hitting inside the line
down the line just a little ways from
third base the mayhew couldn't quite get
there all right so a man in scoring
position again and here's the pitch
there's a ground ball left side it's
through the hole of base hit hernandez
is racing for the plate here comes the
throw by gallo it's not in time yanni
with a head first dive is in there that
was just a ground ball but there was no
one there so texas takes a three nothing
lead line drive oh nice stab by urshella
as connor valepa gets back to first the
deals in the pitch hit on the ground
softly to first voight
touches up to end the inning yankees
have a rally going here in the bottom of
the fifth first and second nobody out
and higashiyoka at the plate
that one is ripped into left center
field peters is on the run he can't get
there it'll go to the wall
porridge scores her shell is being waved
home the relay is bobbled he'll score
it's a two-run double for higashiyoka
the yankees on the board it's 3-2 texas
three to two texas leading the lead in
jeopardy burns pitch to le mayhew he
goes right after the first draw frame
this one out into right field tagging at
third higashiyoka here comes the throw
it's online the tag and they got him
ending over on the double play the
yankees tried to score and
nailed him and man is he celebrating
he's taunting the fans in the right
field corner and having a blast so here
is urshela two outs bases loaded
and that one gets away from trevino
here comes judge he'll score
standing rounds third will stop right
there boy did that kick away there was
the first baseman low who had to
retrieve it and the game is tied at
three and you can hand the lead to
chapman if torres gets a hit here hole
for two with a walk he struck out in the
sixth inning lying to right field that
is going to be a base hit it'll go into
the corner gala will score torres goes
to second with a humongous rbi double
and the yankees lead four to three
soft ground ball can be a tough play and
it booted
and here comes torres here's the throw
torres is
safe he's safe ahead of the tag by
trevino now here's gary sanchez michelle
at first the yankees now have a two-run
lead 5-3
sanchez swings and hits one to deep
center peter's back on the track he's at
the wall she's gone
monument park the crack and cracks one
all the way to monument park and the
yankees have blown open the game oh that
gary is scary
yankees you need one more ouch and
chapman's pitch struck him out swinging
ball game over yankees win
[Applause]
yankees
when